but we're pleased to have back here uh
on the rich eisen show a friend of the
program uh he's been here a couple of
times in person and
we wish that could be the case this time
but we understand what's going on in the
real world and what you can do
um is watch on demand everywhere right
now
a uh great psychological thriller that
was released
on thursday of last week it is a movie
called you should have left
kevin bacon back here on the show how
are you man good
good good to hear your voice good to
hear your voice too what's going on in
your world
uh i'm in um uh
connecticut northwestern connecticut
with my wife okay um
we've never spent this much time
together
we've been married for uh you know 31
years
and this is the longest i think we've
ever um
spent together so it's you know it's
going well i mean
you know considering well i mean that
the fact that there's still plans for a
32nd year of marriage that means things
are going well at this point in time
exactly exactly just yeah i mean
we all know again your your charity is
six degrees.org
you know there has been words about you
know trying to be is
six i guess six feet of separation right
you see where i'm going right now
kevin i think you're putting the pixels
together yeah i'm putting this all
the whole this whole world together uh
have you been spending any time in your
quarantine just flipping on tv and
seeing some of these old sporting events
from back in the day
back in your youth maybe have you
checked anything out anything pop on
your screen that you're like oh gosh i
forgot about all that
well you know i i couldn't get enough of
the last dance i mean i was kind of like
oh it was i i i it was it was the type
of thing where
you know kira wasn't really all that
interested in it you know
and and so i was watching it
um you know i was watching it by myself
so it wasn't the thing that we would sit
down after
after uh after dinner and share together
but
i didn't want it to end i got to the
point where i was i think
was it eight episodes or something i got
to like the second last episode i was
like
ah now what am i gonna do i know right
and we were all covering it in in our
world of sports talk and sports media
covering it like it was a real live
sporting event and
going down memory lane but for i'm
wondering if you had the same
situation that i had being a knick fan
uh
recounting all the near misses and all
the shoulda
could have been if it wasn't for michael
jordan kevin well yeah
it was but it was also sort of like
doubly like i i was decking with a
friend and i said
this is a rough this is a rough episode
but but then but then it then it kind of
came
and i sort of got over it and then it
kind of came back to um
and hit me you know seeing how great uh
reggie miller was
and then i was thinking about reggie in
the garden
and you know anyway uh
but i but it was it was it was it was
something else you know and
and uh i guess i
i don't know i was just i was just you
know
the great documentary filmmaking is is
just something special um
yeah and and for you to you know go down
your memory lane like that for me it was
very difficult just to see how
you know jordan had a specific animus
for the knicks and a specific
uh you know beating ewing as a
collegiate and then
then just destroying pretty much every
opportunity he ever had as a pro was
just very difficult for me to watch but
it was great just seeing all the all the
anger and all the angst of
of those days just still being played
out and my favorite stuff was jordan
getting
handed the ipad by the director so he
could react to some of the stuff that
was being said about him
and i i you didn't want to be that
person on the ipad you just didn't want
to be that person
no i know i know you could just see his
eyes start to light up
i have to say though speaking of ewing i
thought um
you know patrick didn't get a lot of
screen time but i thought he hadn't
lived with a lot of grace
well gosh man yes he sure did and so
many different other people did and i'm
glad you caught that
uh any anything from your uh your your
work
that you flipped on you saw oh god i
first did my own work
no i just nothing no i didn't no no but
just you're flipping around and there's
something from your
from from your world that just popped on
the screen that just even for a second
nothing uh no it's not nothing uh that
hasn't i haven't been flipping around
and and i've actually gotten very kind
of we've gotten very specific about our
screen screen time you know i'm like one
of those people that
even in this kind of a situation i have
to feel like i'm
working so i i'm kind of spending my day
you know in at some kind of work
whatever it happens to be
you know and uh and and so
i haven't been kind of you know channel
surfing at all and then you know we we
have a decision
we have a discussion over dinner about
uh what it is that we're gonna
um you know watch and then we sit down
and uh
do that together after dinner okay so
you're not just sitting down and
watching anything from
either one of your you or your wife's
back uh
back in the day at work the funny you
hear actors say this all the time and i
know people just don't really think this
is true
and i don't want to say that i don't
look at my movies because in the process
of making the movie
i look at it a lot like i really like to
look at the dailies
i like to look at if if i'm
in a position where i can see the first
editors cut i would love to see that or
the director's cut
you know i like to see the various
stages of it i like to see it with an
audience
and then once it's out i kind of say
goodbye to it
so the only times that anything ever
really
pops up is um
when i you know met some kind of a uh
you know if they've cut together some
kind of a clip reel
yeah or uh you know a tribute type of
thing and then and then you see a scene
you go oh yeah and generally i'm like oh
god i'm so glad
i mean i can't i wish i wish i was a
little bit uh
more supportive of my past work but
one thing that's been kind of funny
though is um
i uh one of my jobs that i've given
myself
is cleaning out you know this like
massive piles
in the basement that i just really don't
okay you know don't
don't need anymore and so along with
that
are boxes and boxes of vhs and i i
honestly didn't even know if i had a
vhs player but in one of our rooms i
found one
and so i started to um sit down and go
through
some old uh vhs stuff a lot of it is
like
funny things like tv appearances
um you know you know good morning dallas
or something
and and you know i'm looking because
people just send it to you know and i'm
looking at this stuff and going oh my
god what was i thinking
like for a lot of reasons either you
know the hair
or the look or the stuff that was coming
out of my mouth you know
um but so that's been amusing
one really cool one really cool thing
that i did find
which i was really excited about was
when we made apollo 13
we filmed on a zero g airplane
uh that nasa has for training um
astronauts in in zero gravity and uh
it's it's a pretty cool thing you you
it's a regular airplane you fly out over
the gulf of mexico and you climb and you
die
i don't know if you and i've ever talked
about it but it is
it's a really extreme way to uh get zero
gravity
because as you go over the top of this
uh what they call a parabola it's like
being on a roller coaster
you float for uh 25 seconds
and they actually built our sets
up there and we shot a lot of the zero g
stuff actually in zero g while flying
out in this
in this crazy plane they call the vomit
comic because it's incredibly
uh nauseating yeah and
uh there was a whole bunch of behind the
scenes footage that i found
of uh myself and hanks and
uh the late great bill paxton and and
ron howard you know floating around as
he directs and us
you know doing flips and and you know
drinking out of the air and stuff like
that
it was kind of like what was happening
off the set you know and that was really
fun
no kidding so and that's that's
something was on a vhs tape that you
found
that's where it was yeah it was on a vhs
tape it said apollo 13
um uh behind the scenes zero g footage
and in fact i
i i i sent it
to uh to ron and i don't think he had it
and uh and so i you know i had i had a
transfer
and got it over here no you tried to
transfer i mean you still have your own
coffee
i mean you had a chance yeah yeah
fantastic
you know apollo 13 kevin isn't it again
we'll talk about your your current film
in a second apollo 13 is a
a remote drop for me but doesn't matter
where i am in it i
i drop the remote i have to watch it all
the way to the end and then i
i did check it out after watching the
spacex
um launch the other day seriously like
in a way that when i watch golf i want
to play golf
when i watched that launch i wanted to
watch more and that i had to watch that
you're the movie honestly it's that
beaut it's that great a movie
it really is kevin a policy it's a good
one i was really
i was really thrilled to be part of it
and uh and and
not not the least of which was having
that
incredible experience i mean we did that
thing over 600 times
and nasa up until that point
hadn't really allowed any civilians to
be on that plane that was just something
that was only being used for for
astronaut training
and again i don't know if you're you're
on twitter all that much kevin but uh
one thing that i do see
more than anything else of you is people
using your all as well
uh meme from uh animal house to try and
calm everyone down with everything
that's going on in the world
i see that all as well all the time
kevin is it a pretty strange use of that
theme isn't it i have i have seen that
yeah
all is well um so uh
let's talk about you should have left
how many how many i i guess
scary movies have you done how many have
you done
oh wow um like
been more than more than a few scary bad
movies but
um i i i the first scary movie i did
was i just happened to stumble into
uh one that became very very uh
iconic which was the very first friday
the 13th that's right
and i was just you know young actor
out of work and you know needed to pay
the rent so
it's not like i was like i want to be in
a horror movie that was not
you know i mean i always liked scary
movies but it wasn't that wasn't the
you know there was no driving force
about around me i didn't i wasn't really
making the choices of what i wanted to
be and or didn't want to be and so that
started a whole
uh you know chain of events of of
slasher movies and specifically of that
uh
uh you know friday the 13th thing and um
and then uh i did uh tremors and i did
um
and and the movie you should have left
uh really was
the genesis of that was uh i did a a
really good
uh scary movie called uh
stir of echoes 20 years ago and the
writer and director of stir of echoes
david kepp and i remained friends
and uh i was always
wanting to do another project with him
and kept kind of like
you know begging him to to write
something that that i could be in
and it took 20 years but i just
eventually wore him down
and um and then we went off and made he
should have left
and um so you you've done you've been
there and done that for that
sort of thing so what did you like about
you should have left that people should
be
tuning in you know it's it's the fir
what's
the it's the kind of scary movie that i
like where it has a basis in
character and in emotion
and the first part of the movie is
really a movie about
a marriage and most specifically about a
second marriage and i began a guy who's
married to a woman that's really
way too young for him and he has
um he has stuff in his past that
that he's sort of trying to run away
from but he also has a tremendous amount
of paranoia
uh being married to an actress and being
married to a young actress
and and being worried that you know
she's not being faithful to him and and
they tried to
uh kind of
you know escape right before she's going
to go back into
uh a job and just you know have a
weekend with with
with his wife and him and and their
their six-year-old
child and and uh
so they picked this house in wales
uh she's gonna be working in london and
so they they look for a house in in
in wales and to say that they picked the
wrong house would be
the understatement that's uh
you should have left uh which is
available on demand everywhere now and
it's again was released last thursday
um city on a hill is a great show man uh
is that a
when we get through this whole nightmare
uh you're back out there doing it is
that uh
is that the word where it stands right
now i certainly hope so i certainly hope
though
i'm i'm um i'm hopeful and uh
you know i haven't heard anything
definite yet but
uh we're just starting to see people
talk about and explore how um how
production could resume and
and that's the thing that i'm supposed
to supposed to do next
i hope so it's a great show man you're
great in it you're dynamite in it as
well
and i know that's what you've been on
last couple times promoting um
thank you so no you're welcome thanks
for the time kevin always appreciate our
chats
immensely great to talk to you right
back at you that's kevin bacon you got
it that's
kevin bacon on twitter and instagram you
should have left available on demand
everywhere now
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here